it's hard to imagine a more bruising
first month from a bank of England
bailout and polling slump to signs of
division from the top down at an
extraordinary Party Conference one of
the potentially early missteps on the
political side was to form an
Administration that was so heavily
weighted to those that were on one side
of the leadership contest tomorrow
Parliament is back and many Tory MPS
want a clear signal the government is
changing course if we can start to get
into the territory where inflation's
beginning to fall the government's got a
better relationship with its back
benches it's probably then built a
platform on which it can begin to
incrementally inch its way back into
Political contention today the
chancellor bowed to pressure bringing
forward his fiscal plan with an
independent economic forecast from the
23rd of November to the end of this
month but his options for Market
reassurance remain limited the big worry
for the markets is that the Chancellor's
mini budget is going to rely too heavily
on debt so it's going to be a challenge
challenge for him to try to reassure the
markets he needs to show real fiscal
discipline and show that he is willing
to pay for some of these tax cuts
through a reduction in spending
studying the markets is one thing
winning over Tory MPS is another today
some nerves were calmed by the
announcement that Whitehall veteran
James bowler would become the treasury's
top civil servant and Rishi sunak's
close Ally Greg Hans has been announced
as a new trade Minister a clear sign the
prime minister is trying to reach out
the criticism you hear leveled at Liz
truss again and again from MPS including
some ministers I've spoken to is that
she hasn't done enough to reach out to
all parts of the party clearly that's
something she's trying to change this
week she's inviting MPS for lunch in
Downing Street she'll be touring the tea
rooms after prime minister's questions
and on Wednesday evening she'll be
meeting the 1922 Committee of back bench
MPS she is trying to reset draw a line
under a chaotic few weeks
and capitalizing on chaos labor you say
they're willing to work with rebellious
Tories to get benefits raised in line
with inflation I don't think it's for
the government to tell anybody else uh
what's sensible because they've been
totally irresponsible they know we know
that benefits should be increased in
line with inflation
any decision on benefits will come next
month but already it's sparked around
the Prime Minister doesn't need arriving
at Downing Street today Liz truss now
knows her government need to recalibrate
if she's to win back the trust of the
party and the public Ali full Sky News
Westminster